[Music]
today my dear
everybody is Charlie we got our Flash
finale coming next week and I know it
seems like everything is lost but
there's so much information that they
haven't told us because of what happened
in this moment with iris last night so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway in just a reminder if you're
new to the channel I always name the
giveaway winners at the end of videos so
rather than go through this in a linear
way let's talk about like the most
important thing remember there are a
couple theories about how iris West can
still be alive
buts avatar has killed her in this
moment here one of the biggest theories
is that while Barry was going
Ghostbusters on Savitt our HR swapped
iris and face changed himself so he was
the ones that died but in this promo we
see a picture of HR looking really
downtrodden like oh my god we failed
just like Joe is slumping down oh my god
my daughter's dead so just based on the
information in this trailer it seems
like what they did is they actually did
kill iris in this moment and even though
I do think that she's going to be alive
in season 4 the way that she's going to
come back is going to be different there
are a couple other possibilities and the
biggest one is all about Captain Cold
solution don't try to beat him at his
own game so remember how Barry was sort
of choosing the wrong option like
fighting force with force he tried to
takes avatar down with the gun he was
trying to use sabotage methods to take
him down so what is like the other
option using his goodness to stops
avatar there was a big scene with
Caitlin and sabot are in the episode
where he explained that pretty much the
whole reason for doing this is that he
feels disposable in that nobody loves
him so obviously there's some way to fix
that but I think what the show is trying
to tell us is there's no other way that
Barry can stop up he can create the time
remnants but that will just lead to
another savat are because sabotage will
kill them all but leave one alive just
like future Barry did that led to the
creation of this version of sabotage it
might have something to do with the
video that iris recorded because we
watched it from her perspective like we
watched her over the finale moment that
she was being killed as she was
recording it she was saying her wedding
vows to Barry we haven't watched other
people watch that video yet we haven't
seen avatar look at the video we haven't
seen Barry look at the
you there's also a missing period of
time where iris is with avatar like they
didn't go straight from Earth to to this
moment here they went somewhere else for
a while you have that then you have all
the plans the team flash made when Barry
wasn't around so there's a couple big
chunks of time where we don't know what
happened in there a couple other moments
here in this footage that imply that not
all is lost even though everyone feels
probably downtrodden like oh my god hope
is lost how will a hero survive like
they have all those texts that they cut
into this but you cease avatar opening a
portal to the Speed Force today is the
day that I become a god we don't even
know what's avatar thinks is going to
happen like he thinks he's going to be
all-powerful like he's going to become a
Speed Force wormhole alien himself or
something like that they totally haven't
explained that part of the equation so
that's why I keep going back to that
iris proposal message that she recorded
on the phone maybe there's something
that Barry can do to use his goodness to
appeal to sabotage as well as the Speed
Force wormhole aliens because we also
keep going back to the idea that they're
allowing this to play out the black
flash is nowhere to be seen he could
probably take down sabotage he has the
ability to just leech life force from
speedsters so the funny thing in this
last episode is the Captain Cold was
kind of giving him the same lesson that
Speed Force wormhole alien Captain Cold
was giving him way back in episode 16
look at all these people that have
suffered from your decisions Barry like
he's the one that takes him to see Wally
West in that Speed Force prison who
looks like he's being forced to watch
the death of his mother over and over
maybe that would be Barry's prison too
so if sabotage is a version of Barry
then that's probably what he's forced to
relive over and over too so it seems
like right now the only way to fix this
is to turn savitur around so that Barry
can sort of retro actively fix the
timeline because no matter what he does
right now going back in time creating
time remnants it all leads to another
Savitt are in sort of like this infinite
loop the mobius strip that cisco drew
that is sabotage timeline remains intact
there's always a version of Savitt are
traveling somewhere along this that'll
come back and make this all play out the
same way we all probably think this is
going to end with Barry serving penance
by going into the Speed Force
effectively dying even though when
speedsters die
they just go into the speedforce you
can't kill energy it just changes form
so Barry would just become pure energy
for a period of time until something
brings him back to earth so he's never
going to be gone from the TV show
forever but if you're a big Game of
Thrones fan I feel like they're going to
do their Jon Snow season 5 - season 6
twist this year where it's like oh my
god is he going to come back what's
happening and then of course yes he's
coming back so just remember when
speedsters die they're heaven is the
Speed Force the biggest questions I've
seen mostly have to do with what the
powers of the flash are like what can he
do to stops avatar and really what
they're trying to present Barry with
this season is the unwinnable scenario
like no power that he comes up with no
new trick that he learns is going to
help him stops avatar so that's the real
conflict how can you achieve victory if
you can't fight your villain away like
what's the solution to that in one of
the most fun things about this show is
that they almost don't know anything
about how the Speed Force works they
didn't know about the Philosopher's
Stone being a calcified piece of Speed
Force energy and you can kind of see
that the twist that will bring Barry
back and season four and the things that
they'll push into in future season
season five season six however long the
show goes will have to do with a lot of
the big mysteries that they haven't
fully explained yet like we don't even
know what a Speed Force wormhole alien
is how did they come into existence what
grant purpose do they have for Barry
Allen how do they feel about the
reverse-flash how is he going to come
back so just be thinking about that when
you're thinking about future seasons
they always take big comic-book concepts
and then try to do their own spin on
them so once the season is over I'll do
another savat are video that'll explain
all the comic book changes and the way
the arc played out the comic book
storylines that they adapted but it only
seems like all is lost all is not lost
there's always something that you can do
what's going to happen next is I'll do a
video for the agents of shield finale
there were a lot of really crazy things
that happen and they pretty much explain
where they're going in season 5 there's
a couple of teasers that drop that all
do videos for and there will be some
more flash this weekend obviously
because it's the finale there'll be a
little extra flash but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Dylan
Saunders please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details and just a reminder
- there's going to be
a new round of the giveaway every week
through the summer so I will keep doing
plastering stuff there will be weekly
flash bonus videos DC TV there's Titan
stuff that we got to talk about so think
about the bonus videos you guys want me
to do during the break after the finale
drops don't forget to Game of Thrones is
going to be happening this summer and
I'm going to be doing the same types of
videos like I did for flash for Game of
Thrones it's going to be crazy while you
wait for that click here for my flash
video and click here for brand new Rick
and Morty thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight